Hello, everyone.
So today I'm gonna look at whether
monopolies are allocatively efficient.
Allocatively efficient is the idea that the firm is
operating in the best interest of consumers
and aiming to maximize social welfare.
Diagramatically,
the allocatively efficient point can be illustrated
with M C equals A R.
The allocatively efficient point on the diagram
illustrates that
for a monopoly to be allocatively efficient,
the price that they would set should be lower
and the output that they produce should be higher.
Monopolies, however,
seek to profit, maximize,
and therefore set a price of P m.
And a quantity of output of Q m.
And therefore,
monopolies are not allocatively efficient,
as the price that they set
is higher than the allocatively efficient point,
and the quantity of output that they set is restricted
compared to the allocatively efficient point.